dry season schmiesing it's a new week
and that means it's time for new
releases and this week we got some good
releases well first up your buddies at
Double Fine have a Metroidvania style
game they want you to try it's called
head Lander as you might come to expect
from both Double Fine and publish your
adult swim games this one's pretty weird
head Lander takes place in a futuristic
setting inspired by 1970 science fiction
television shows and movies you know
like Logan's Run basically everyone in
the future ditches their bodies and
uploads their consciousness into a robot
but an evil AI is controlling the robot
so people are just stuck in that robot
they can't control it you play as the
only human consciousness that can move
but you're just a head don't you worry
you're a powerful head and you can put
yourself on these different robots to
help control them and save the day I
told you it was weird you can get ahead
on the 26th so you guys remember seeing
really like weird puzzle game or you
like hacked into computers to access
doors and stuff no not that one yeah
that's the stuff I'm talking about
quadrilateral cowboy takes place in the
high tech pass to the 80s when you had a
top-notch pc with 56.6 kilobytes modem
and 256 kilobytes of RAM at the powerful
setup you're a hacker working with top
notch agents to infiltrate buildings and
steal documents but unlike some hacking
games you're really using code to break
down the cameras and security systems
feel the thrill of being a programmer
you become anonymous on the 25th also
this week you're continuing your portal
journey in search of home in minecraft
story mode episode 7 but Jesse and cruel
and in a world entirely controlled by
Palma a sinister thinking machine
determined to command everyone and
everything in pursuit of optimal
usefulness and efficiency forced on the
run to avoid capture and assimilation
you'll have to work with a new ally to
defeat the corrupt computer and free the
population it's enslaved there's no end
in sight to this episodic adventure and
it wouldn't be surprised if they just
kept making these and turn it into a
regular series the people love it and
you can grab episode 7 on the 26
hyper light drifter that gorgeous 2d
action platformer with music by the
talented disaster piece is coming to
console this week which ones you ask
well eventually all of them but this
week we're getting xbox one and ps4 the
game 1 over reviewer kevin van noord
praising the game's visual storytelling
and fluid fighting mechanics all set to
a whimsical world you can't wait to
explore if you miss this on PC this is
an excellent chance to play on console
become the drifter on the 26th finally
you might have noticed that I freaking
love stardew valley and if you ever
wanted to play but you didn't have a PC
which was the only platform it was
available on you're in luck now it's on
mac and linux let me paint you a picture
of leaving your job being out on a farm
starting a new planting crops and
finding secrets meeting the town people
falling in love and mining for goodies
make in your house oh there's so much to
do this games awesome and you're gonna
love it that you should totally get it I
can't really speak any higher about it
if you guys liked harvest moon you're
gonna love this game and that's it for
this week remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they change next week we'll be
back see you then
you